here's our wild money move of the week
it actually has to do with the nfl
player
wild money move of the week nfl player
odell beckham jr let's pull him up on
the on the um
on the screen otherwise known on social
medias as obj
he dropped 1.8 million dollars
on diamond
teeth
in the back
of his mouth his his top
two
back teeth all the way back there what
is that he put diamond carrot
crosses
on the back huh of his
mouth so look a couple points here you
guys good okay couple points here look
if i'm dropping 1.8 million dollars on
what is what basically came out to a 13
carat
diamond on your teeth
i'm putting that right in the front
of my face right on your forehead right
on my forehead exactly little uzi vert
style i'll put that right on top of my
forehead or possibly on my two front
teeth if you're gonna drop almost two
million dollars to put
diamonds in the back of your mouth right
what's going on there you doing buddy
you're think about it that's just you're
eating you're chewing hopefully you're
flossing shout out to the dentist out
there you're flossing
you're doing whatever with your mouth
yeah you got two million bucks hiding in
there like does it make a girl feeling
better or anything like does the what
like like when you kiss a girl or
something like does she get some
pleasure out of that or she thinks out
of the back
back your teeth
how do you kiss girls paul i don't know
basically if i'm dropping that kind of
money it's going to go you're going to
see that immediately when you see me
i'll be shining shining shining shining
but
anyway
so here's the question if you had to if
you had to
drop 1.8 million dollars cash you had to
spend it
what would you do with it apparently od
uh obj wanted to put it on diamonds in
the back of his mouth
david what would you do if you had to
spend 1.8 million i had to spend 1.8
million and by the way in the comments
let us know below
you had to spend it you could do
whatever you want with it what would you
do is it on one thing or multiple do
whatever you want
who wants to go first for the sake of
the game let's do one thing sure one
don't you can't say travel that one's
like the easiest one you can travel you
can do whatever you want
okay okay besides traveling because i
feel like everyone would go i'd go
travel i'd or buy real estate if you're
gonna say travel tell me where you're
traveling to bingo how about that
who wants to go first i can go first go
ahead since david didn't speak fast
enough
um
why isn't this
paul go ahead paul
okay um
i would i i would probably take half of
it and invest it for sure mm-hmm that
way that you know the money's keep
working it's working for you were you
investing it go ahead quick and then
living living situation i would
pay the rest of the like like either
rent or buy a place
okay i got you so you'd use it for
lifestyle and for investing nancy you
got to drop 1.8 million dollars you're
not buying a golden tooth what are you
doing
um i mean anything that serves purpose
right so like a nicer house
um a newer car payoff anything mm-hmm
but i don't know if i could spend like
1.8 like right there okay david i'd buy
something ridiculous what would you buy
i don't know something just like this
like something that's just i this is
just i have 1.8 million dollars and i
don't i don't really i'm gonna just get
grills for the back of my teeth because
i can yeah it's kind of like a screw you
almost just because i can so i would get
something that is kind of just like i'm
going to do it just because i can't like
like i'd buy that invisible uh sculpture
that we talked about on the pvd podcast
that one time okay like whatever amount
yeah an invisible nft bingo yeah just
because i can yeah i think you know the
i would not save that money you would
not save them you have to spend it you
have to spend i have to spend it so
obviously the easy answer for me would
be well if i'm going to spend it can i
invest can invest it can i buy
assets can i whether that's real estate
whether that's stocks whether that's
crypto whether that's
um
gold silver or whatever kind of
commodity sure but something that i
think would bring you joy
it's kind of like how it's better to
give than to receive i would donate it i
would find a cause that i think would
really help a cause you truly believe in
like i'm a huge advocate of the special
olympics my friends actually down here
in south florida
run the special olympics it's pretty
cool maybe we i think i think the next
time it does happen when you know cove
and all that valuetainment should
definitely go help with the special
olympics it makes you feel better about
yourself because it makes you appreciate
these people are running around
and just the fact that they're running
around and they win a race while they
lose a race
they're so happy
and it just makes you feel so
damn good that you're helping them
because you're called a hugger called a
hugger you're there to help them to
encourage them right
and um
it makes you feel good feels better
received so
my challenge to and i don't know what
obj does the rest of his money respect
you want to spend your money on golden
teeth or diamond teeth cool yeah i would
tell you to look in the mirror man in
the mirror michael jackson style see how
you can donate that money it'll make you
feel a lot better than having some shiny
teeth uh here's a little fun fact for
obj if he is listening because we'll
move on real quick stats show that up to
of nfl players go bankrupt or fall into
severe financial stress within two years
of retirement two years odell beckham is
28 he's been injured of the last two out
of the last three seasons he was famous
for playing on the giants one hand grab
sick grab we get that now he's on
cleveland he's been injured my boy my
doppelganger baker mayfield
um so we'll see how long he plays i
think he's made 50 million in his career
it's not like he's some broke dude
whatsoever exactly but i know people
that make millions that go broke but
in the nfl you know national football
league nfl you know what it also stands
for familiar not for long dawg by the
time he's probably 33's maybe got five
years left he might not even be in the
league okay he might not even be in the
league so
uh that's my two cents on uh on odell
beckham
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken